Mel B has sounded off about Victoria
Beckham not popping up on the reunion
tour but posh spice told us it was never
going to happen
your friend Mel B says you might be
hitting up when we stadium June 14 ya
know Melanie's always been like that
letter but I will not be going on
standards I expected her to come and
just say hi at least you know on stage
no even I'm still just as an audience
like members supporting why don't do I
look like I know I don't know Mel B
couldn't hide her disappointment on good
morning Britain that Victoria miss all
13 tour dates of the Spice Girls reunion
tour she was a wedding with the lost
Shay wedding
Spice Girls come on this isn't the first
time Mel has made her feelings known in
fact during the tour she called Victoria
out while on stage the fact we can come
back together
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a rift no I mean we're all adults
you know but it is a bit disappointing
let's put it that way
a source tells ET that there are no
plans for future spy school tour dates
but Melfi has her sights down under I
did suggest that we continue it and I
think you should just go to Australia
and February
[Music]